[MUSIC PLAYING]
ADAM TISHOK: Welcome to
"Cloud OnAir," live webinars
from Google Cloud.
We're hosting webinars
every Tuesday.
My name's Adam Tishok.
I'm a product manager
on Google Slides.
Today, I'll be talking to
you about tips and tricks
to boost productivity
in Google Slides.
In this webinar, we're going
to walk through the process
of creating a presentation.
I'll be highlighting
features in Slides that can
help you be more productive.
You can ask questions throughout
the webinar on the platform.
We have Googlers on standby
to help answer them.
Let's get started.
Presentations are a staple
in many business settings.
When done right,
they can help tell
a story that can captivate,
persuade, and inspire.
Although they're
a powerful tool,
they can take a lot of
time to put together.
Fortunately, Google Slides
has several features
to make the creation of
presentations more efficient.
In this talk,
we're going to walk
through the typical
lifecycle of a presentation.
We're going to talk about
getting a head start,
the collaboration
features of Google Slides,
how to put polish on
your presentation,
and presenting your
final presentation.
Typically, it's best to
kick off the workflow
using existing information or
templates to get a head start.
And after getting
started, you will likely
need to work with your
teammates and stakeholders
to get all of the
necessary information,
and collaborate on
building the presentation.
But before finalizing
and presenting,
you want to add an
extra level of polish
to make your slides look
on-brand and professional.
And finally, you share
out the presentation
or present it in person.
While I go through
this presentation,
I'm going to highlight how
Google Slides saves you
time during each of
these four steps.
Getting a head-start.
Let's talk about how to
start a presentation.
If I were to poll the
audience right now
about how they started
putting together
their last presentation,
the majority of people
would probably say, they started
by making a copy of an existing
presentation, then cleaning
up all of the old content,
and replacing it
with new content.
Although this is a
very common practice,
it's not the most efficient
way to make presentations.
A better way is to
maintain clean templates
with placeholders.
Templates save time, and
they're an important tool
for most businesses,
because time
spent recreating
files in the workplace
takes away from the
time your team has
to do more creative work.
However, finding those
templates across a large company
can be time-consuming,
and often impossible.
To help with this, Google
Slides offers a template gallery
that makes finding the
right template easy,
because it can be
customized for your company
with unique templates
created by your employees.
With the template
gallery in Google Slides,
companies can distribute their
up-to-date templates and group
them by team or purpose.
A template that's
custom to your team
will give you a
head start so you
can focus less on
formatting, and more
on driving impact and
developing the right content
for your audience.
With Google Slides
templates, you
can also create
presentations that scale.
We talked about
starting off a template
and customizing it to
produce your end result.
But what if you need to produce
10 of these slide decks?
They all need the
same formatting,
but have slightly
different content.
In certain job
functions, like sales,
this is a very common workflow.
The sales associate needs
to have the same pitch
deck that they tweak slightly
for various customers.
This customization's not fast,
and often prone to human error.
You make a copy of
the template, change
the name of the customer,
the corresponding data,
and then you do that one slide
deck at a time, over and over
again.
Google Slides has an API to
help streamline and error-proof
this process.
Google Slides offers both a
REST API and Apps Script API
to give users
programmatic access
to create and update
presentations in Slides
from any data source.
Your team can build
ready-to-go presentations
to turn business data
into presentations,
and streamline the
slide-creation process.
With these APIs, you can use
your internal tools, templates,
and your customer data
to fill in placeholders
across various
versions of the pitch
decks you need with
just one click.
While templates give you a
head start with formatting
and layout, what about
getting a head start
on the content in
your presentation?
To help ensure you always have
the most up-to-date content,
we built a feature
called linked slides.
We've built this
feature because we
know convincing and
powerful presentations often
have data and slides
from other sources.
And we have feedback that this
is a common workflow for many
of you.
You have a few
slides from old decks
that you want to reuse
in a new presentation,
over and over again.
But repeatedly copying
slides from one presentation
to another as they get
updated is a major time sink,
and can be easy to miss
subtle, but important, changes.
Now, with linked
slides, you can link
and sync slides from
multiple presentations.
You know they need
updated because
in the right-hand corner,
you'll see an update button.
This way, you can maintain
a single source of truth,
and update content
in new presentations
to match your source
of truth with just
the click of a button.
This can be great for
important presentations
like quarterly business reviews.
We also expanded the same
linking functionality
to content within slides.
We know that a lot of
business data lives in Sheets.
So we expanded this
linking functionality such
that you can also link tables
and charts that you copy over
from Sheets files.
When the table in
Sheets is updated,
or the corresponding
chart is updated,
you'll see that
same update button
in the right-hand corner
of the table or chart,
telling you that
there is new data
to pull into your presentation.
If the original chart or table
changes without being linked,
it can be tedious and
time-consuming to replace it
in each and every file.
This feature saves
you valuable time,
and we make it possible to
update your chart with just
a single click, without
the need to ever leave
the context of your
document or presentation.
Now that you have
a good starting
point with a consistent
format and slides,
charts and tables linked
from your previous work,
you're ready to bring in your
teammates to get their insights
and feedback.
Let's see how Google Slides
can help you collaborate.
Google Slides keeps all of
its content in the cloud.
This means that there is no
need to create multiple versions
of decks, emailed back and
forth between teammates with
confusing version names
like v1, v1.2, v2, v2 final.
We've all seen these.
And it can be confusing to
know who updated what and when.
Syncing the content
from multiple people
in multiple versions of
files can be a job in itself.
With Google Slides,
the whole team
works from the same file
with realtime collaboration.
What you see on screen
is how collaboration
works in Google Slides.
Multiple people are making
changes in real time.
And even if they're working
in different time zones,
in different parts
of the word, you
don't have to deal
with version roulette,
because everyone's
working on the same file.
But collaboration in Slides
is more than just content
on a presentation.
Comments in Slides also
allow your team members
to leave suggestions or
notes on what to edit or add.
You can also assign an
action item to someone
by mentioning their
name in a comment
and checking the
Action Item box.
The assignee will get an email.
And the next time
they enter the file,
they'll see the action
items clearly highlighted
with a blue bar.
This allows for clear task
delegation and faster teamwork.
That's because all
of the collaborators
know who needs to
contribute and where
their contributions are needed.
We also know that teams are
often working on the go,
while commuting to the
office or on business trips.
To help accommodate
this, we continually
invest in our
mobile apps to make
sure you have access to all the
functionality you need wherever
you are.
Our apps are available
on both iOS and Android.
And the same realtime
collaboration features,
along with all the formatting
and content creation tools
you could need to create
a quick presentation,
make a minor edit, or
respond to a comment.
Our mobile apps also have some
unique functionality that's
optimized for being on-the-go.
You can sync presentations so
they're available on the app
while offline, and use
the mobile app Present
mode to turn your phone
into a presentation remote.
Apart from
collaborators, we know
that stakeholders and approvers
are often part of the process
to create a presentation.
You often need to get
your presentation approved
by stakeholders in various
functions like legal and PR.
The combination of Google
Slides and Google Drive
can help with this.
Without G Suite,
you would probably
download the slide
shows as PDFs,
then use project-tracking tools
to collect formal approvals
and sign-offs.
While that would technically
work, if any of the approvers
asked for a change
in the presentation,
you would need to produce new
copies of the files or PDFs
and re-send them for approvals.
As I said earlier, version
roulette isn't fun for anyone.
With G Suite, this
approval workflow
is a whole lot more streamlined.
We recently announced
Drive's upcoming
document-centric
workflows feature,
which will allow users
to get formal approvals
on their files.
With this feature, you can
submit slide decks for approval
from specific coworkers.
Upon doing so, the file
gets locked, and shared,
and sent to the approvers.
After the file's
approved, it stays locked.
If someone looks at the
file after it's approved,
they'll be able to tell
clearly it has been approved,
and that's the final version.
This lightweight workflow
tool can powerfully
streamline company
processes and will soon
be available in an
early adopter's program.
Along the same lines, when
you have many stakeholders
and collaborators, it can
be really helpful to track
their progress.
With other, legacy
presentation tools,
after you send your presentation
to a teammate, you have no idea
if or when they looked at it.
It can be hard to understand
who has seen what,
and this can slow down teamwork.
Google Slides now
offers the ability
to view collaborator activity.
The Activity
dashboard allows you
to see which collaborators
viewed your slide deck
and when, giving you the
power to track progress
on the project with
many moving parts.
You can find the Activity
Dashboard in the Tools
drop-down in the main menu.
With this tool,
you can understand
which of your teammates have
seen your latest revision,
and who needs to be pinged
to stay in the loop.
Once the core parts of your
presentation, like the message,
data, visuals are all ready,
you start worrying about
the fine-grained details--
the polish that makes
your presentation
feel professional and tells the
story best for your audience.
Google Slides has some great
tools to help with this.
As you and your
collaborators add content,
you will likely
need to rearrange
the layout of your slides.
With the power of
machine intelligence,
we built the Explore
feature in Slides,
so you can just drop your
content on the slide,
and with a couple
of clicks, you'll
have slides that
look so good, people
will think you hired a
design agency for them.
We match slide
themes and layouts
to best fit your content.
There's no cropping, resizing,
or reformatting required.
This Explore tool
is so compelling
because it really does
save time by taking away
mundane formatting tasks.
We've seen that people who use
Explore to select their layouts
save over 60% of
the time that they
would have spent formatting.
So even if design
isn't your expertise,
rest assured that
Slides can help
make sure you have a beautiful
presentation to be proud of.
And although Slides
Explore is great,
it needs you to
supply the content.
And we know that another problem
in creating presentations
is finding the right
visuals or stock
photography that help deliver
the message to your audience.
Luckily, Slides has a
platform to help with that.
In Google Slides,
we have a feature
called Add-ons that
help you source
these high-quality visuals
from a variety of sources.
Previously, I spoke about APIs.
Apps Script is one
of these, and it's
an open platform that
allows any developer
to create and publish add-ons
that can be added to Slides.
As a result, we have
a rich add-on store
with a variety of functionality.
In the add-on
store, you can find
tools that help you build
more powerful presentations.
These add-ons can enable
you to source beautiful,
full-bleed pictures, use
advanced formatting tools,
or include diagrams you created
in programs outside of G Suite.
For example, you can
search for and add pictures
from Adobe Stock
right in Slides.
Or you can use the
Shutterstock add-on,
adding customized
photos within Slides.
Teams can benefit from even more
powerful capabilities in Slides
with additional add-ons
from Balsamiq, Lucidchart,
Pear Deck, Noun
Project, and Unsplash.
These tools help
bring your content
that's external to Slides
directly into your G Suite
workflows.
Google Slides also has
several native tools
to help with the polish you need
to get your deck just right.
One of the areas
we've been focusing
is increased font support.
We know fonts matter.
There are some fonts that
are good for documents
that are read on
a personal screen,
while others are good
on the big screen.
And different fonts
can really help
you to find the tone and
narrative of your presentation.
Today, in Google Slides, you
can choose from over 800 fonts
via the More Fonts menu.
In this menu, you can
preview our diverse catalog
of fonts, which supports
62 languages, including
non-latin scripts like
Cyrillic and [INAUDIBLE]..
Once you find fonts you
like in the More Fonts menu,
you can add them
to My Fonts List.
And once they're in
your My Fonts List,
you have quick access to those
fonts in the Font drop-down.
Another great native design
tool that Google Slides offers
is the Slide Master.
This is an advanced
feature that allows
you to control all
of the information
about theme, layout, background,
color, fonts, and positioning
of all the slides in your deck.
Using the Slide Master
can be an easy way
to perform bulk updates
in your presentation,
or to ensure new slides always
have the right starting point.
By using the Slide
Master, you can
make sure the default
fonts, colors,
and placeholders on
your layouts are always
set-up to look
great, helping you
create professional
presentations quickly.
It's also great to use the Slide
Master when creating templates
for your company
that you'll then
upload to the template gallery
that I mentioned earlier.
While the Slide Master
is great for making
wide-reaching changes, we
know that for certain slides,
you care about each
and every pixel.
Aligning an object or
a text box perfectly
can be tedious and
difficult. So Google Slides
offer rulers, as well as static
guides, to help with consistent
placement and alignment
throughout a presentation.
You can turn on rules and
guides in the View menu.
Once they're on, you can
right-click to add new guides,
and drag guides to the exact
location you need them to be.
The guides will show
it to all of the slides
in the presentation so that
text boxes and other objects
will snap to the location
that you care about,
and you can ensure that
they're all aligned across all
of the slides in your deck.
Now that you and
your collaborators
have added all of
your content and data,
gotten the approvals
needed, and everything
is polished and
buttoned-up, you're
ready to present your work.
Whether you're presenting
from your mobile device
or your laptop, via G Suite
Meet, or on a big screen,
the Presenter view in Google
Slides gives you as a present
a special view into
the presentation.
The Presenter view helps
you be a better presenter
with features like speaker
notes, quick slide navigation,
and a laser pointer.
Speaker notes allow you
to craft your message
and have access to
all the notes that you
need to give a great
presentation, right
at your fingertips.
Our quick navigation
tools in Presenter view
allow you to quickly navigate
to any slide in your deck
if you need to revisit a
specific point or visual.
And at any time, you can
turn on a laser pointer
to direct the attention
of your audience
to a certain part
of the presentation.
In Presenter view,
you also have access
to a feature unique
to Google Slides--
Q&A. With Q&A, you can
better engage your audience
by allowing them to
submit questions and vote
on them during Google
Slides presentations.
Once you start a Q&A session,
Slides displays a unique URL
that audience members can
go to and submit questions.
You can decide when to
answer the questions
and display them right on
the big screen, one by one.
The audience members can
also vote on the questions
other people submit,
so you know where
to focus your time
if you only have
a few minutes for questions.
This concludes the journey
of a typical presentation.
I hope you learned about
some Slides features
you may not have been aware of.
And as a quick
recap, Slides helps
you get started with tools
like templates and APIs.
It facilitates
realtime collaboration
with comments and action items.
You can let Slides be your
personal designer with Slides
Explore.
And finally, you can have
confidence with Slides
that help give you the power
to give a great presentation,
and host a live Q&A
with an audience.
If you want to learn
more about Google Slides,
you can visit the G
Suite Learning Center.
That's a wrap for today.
Please stay tuned
for a live Q&A. We'll
be back in less than a minute.
Welcome back.
We have a couple of
questions from the audience
that I'd like to answer.
The first question is,
after final creation,
can Google Slides
work in offline mode?
That's a great question.
The answer's yes.
In Google Slides, you can
make all of the slides files
that you want available
in offline mode.
And when you make
changes offline,
as soon as you go back
online, those changes
will be synced to the
presentation with all
of your other collaborators.
The next question is, can
I share a presentation
I make in Slides with someone
without a G Suite account?
Yes.
There are actually a couple
ways you can do this.
In Slides, you can share the
Present view of the slide deck
and make that public.
And this allows you to share
the content of your presentation
with whoever you want.
There's also ways to download
the content from Slides
into multiple file types,
like PDF or PowerPoint.
The next question is,
how can I prevent someone
from making changes to a
presentation I sent to them?
And how do I limit
access to a presentation
so only people in my
company can see it?
These are also great
questions, and important ones.
So when you share
presentation in Google Slides,
you have the option to provide
different levels of access.
You can provide access to
edit, access to comment,
and access to view.
If you provide access to
edit, the collaborator
can change whatever they
want in and decide with you.
If you provide
access to comment,
they can make
comments on the slide,
but they can't make any changes.
And if you provide
access to view,
the recipient can only view
the contents of the deck.
There is additional advanced
settings in the share menu
that can even prevent you from
letting people copy contents
from the slides to other decks.
In terms of a limit of
access to presentations,
so only people at your
company can see it,
there are the main level
controls at the admin level
that can be set, so
presentations can only
be available within your domain.
Can I add videos to my
slides is the next question.
This is also a great
question, and we
have two ways to do this.
You can embed videos directly
from YouTube into your deck.
And you can also upload
videos from Drive,
that you may have saved
from a variety of sources,
into your deck.
And the last question
is, can I hide some
slides when I'm presenting?
This is actually a feature
we've just recently built,
and it's called skip slides.
When you're in the edit view of
Slides, on the left-hand side,
there's a film strip.
And if you right-click on
a slide in the film strip,
you'll have the
option to skip slides.
If you highlight a slide
and select skip slides,
you'll see an eye icon.
And that means when you present,
that slide will be skipped.
It looks like that's
it for the questions.
So in closing, you can stay
tuned for the next session, how
Nest uses Google Cloud and
Tableau to drive its business.
Thank you very
much for your time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]